all right guys so we got something very
special in the studio today you've been
probably seeing this around the web over
the past number of months from
Transformers and to Carter Tomi this is
a Canon and Transformers collaboration
officially licensed from Canon and of
course working with Takara Tomy with
Transformers it is Optimus Prime
as an R5 the Canon R5 which I have here
courtesy of Ken and Singapore big thanks
to them for allowing me to loan this
camera out to compare it against this
now let's answer a couple questions
right off the bat does this take photos
no
is it a one-to-one scale not exactly is
it cool for camera guys and girls you're
gonna like this but for you others out
there who are wondering does this relate
to some sort of animated series or how
does this fit into the Mythos of
Transformers it doesn't this is just a
very cool collaboration trying to do
something different and unique and
that's what I decided to get it because
I like cameras I like Transformers I
like Optimus Prime so it all kind of fit
into what I enjoy and it's not that
cheap so by the way paying for the
licensing on this so it's around 100 and
almost 200 Singapore dollars thereabouts
it's not that cheap but again we're
importing it from Japan because it's
only available in Japan and big thanks
to uh Falcon Tanger who were very kind
enough to get this for me all right so
let's unbox this we're going to compare
it against the R5 obviously one takes
photos one takes a battery this doesn't
let's get down to talking about it first
and foremost let's look at the Box
there's Optimus Prime transformed there
is the Canon R5 next to it look to the
back of it all in Japanese with a little
bit of English I don't read Japanese
also there's another variation with
refractor as the Canon R5 which I kind
of feel like they could have done
another Canon camera would have been
cool if they did like a 1dx and then an
R5 for Optimus that have at least a
little bit of a interesting Dynamic so
you can buy one and get a different
camera body and then get Optimus to get
the R5 that would have been cool maybe
that'll happen in the future who knows
maybe they'll bring in Nikon since Nikon
is a Japanese camera brand
you never know here at geek culture
we've tested plenty of chairs but Secret
Life gaming chairs remain one of our
favorites whether it's for work or play
they feel great to lean back against
with the ergonomic features offering
support for the whole body from the head
and back
to the arms and even something for your
butt this mix of Form and Function helps
the Titan Evo 2020 to deliver the best
seating experience like no other for
more information check out secretlab.co
by the way I've never transformed this
at all so this is the first time I'm
doing this yeah that is not one-to-one
at all and you get a 24 105 so you get
the kit lens on this one you get a
manual
to walk you through it get a little bit
of a camera body I believe that goes
into optimus's hands with the flip out
display like that because you know the
R5 does have
the flip out rotatable display let's go
to the lens here this is the lens
and this is a 135 this is the 105 24 105
so obviously not one to one scale this
is a larger lens anyway but definitely
not one to one scale who do you get a
lens cap
got to protect your Transformer
well
it's a good question do you know I don't
know
no it doesn't clamp it looks like it
should because there's a hinge in the
back of it unless that transforms into
something else I don't know plastic on
this does feel a little bit inexpensive
so don't go thinking you're going to get
the same quality out of an R5 or a Canon
camera system like this like this
is a legit lens cap this feels good hmm
same but different so this is the Matrix
of leadership that goes inside the lens
as we see on the box it's like a nice
little uh pale blue gem inside of that
pretty cool
pretty nice but it's all about Optimus
Prime
as
the Canon R5 and there we have it
Okay so
let's compare
for you gamma guys out there you already
can tell right away one look this looks
like more like a Canon M50 or R50 I
should say now because they just came
out with a new one we did a review on it
check out the link above to check that
out but uh and this is the R5 so
definitely a difference in size how's
the grip grip is pretty good they still
have the Canon feel to it so it has a
pretty good grip but of course my pinky
doesn't have a home on this camera
system whereas on the R5 it feels so so
good so does the lens mount on it looks
like it should mount on let's see if we
have the Red Dot the Red Dot let's go
for that
it does it mounts up how about that if I
was walking on the street would somebody
think I'm taking a photograph of them
the button here to release the lens
doesn't work it just turns and locks
it's not even a lock switch on it just
kind of turns it just stays stays there
it's very easy just looking at this
right now I felt like you're paying for
the collaboration and not for the
quality of the product if you get what
I'm saying okay so now let's get into
transforming this thing because I have
no clue how to do it
oh great is in Japanese Xeno can you
speak Japanese hello no nope okay great
neither can I shows the top bottom
camera mode everything else does the
display open up and flip out no it does
not
doesn't flip out that's a lot going on
here we are going to fast forward some
of this transformation so you have to
turn you have to put the lens on first
it says the lens cap goes on it but I
can't get this thing to go on
it's not like a tight fit right you need
to screw it oh there it is you got to
push it on got it you got to really push
it on and it only goes in one way so
it's like
yeah so you go from bottom up to get it
on like that so the cap does stay but
it's not this normal cap oh oh oh so
first is you pull
this out
ah next is you pull this out
yeah it does flip open like that then
you bring the legs down then you bring
the door up like that so we're getting
we're starting to see something happen
here now it wants you to move this back
over here
we need to take the feet out ah
this is interesting
see what the feet right here
we put the lips up and then you can
spread the legs as soon as you can
spread the legs here it says says
something in Japanese which I can't
understand to explain how to spread the
legs that sounds wrong doesn't it you
flip up the thing which I just did and
then you can pull out the legs I know
there's an restriction here that's in
Japanese oh there's a button there's
some button here let me see
oh got it okay oh where was it it was
right here there's a latch right there
so you got to kind of pull the latch you
got to pull this portion right there
then it pops open like that so there's
something you bring okay bring this down
first
then you bring this down which okay now
we got now we're back in there
right I think that's what you do
where you can keep it like this and then
this portion
the whole thing goes up
oh oh
man this is a pain this is not easy
nice if you've ever built a third party
of transformative party Transformer it's
like that it's like that both is numbers
it's all in Japanese yeah it's all
Japanese guys this is where we're look
we're looking at this this is what we're
seeing right here and we're trying to
figure this out you got it we got it you
got it sick sick all right cool so this
part comes up yeah
slides in this section slicing with them
ah okay cool so it becomes
oh interesting yeah got a little Batman
Vibe okay cool we're back in action and
just in case you didn't know about The
Branding Canon on one shoulder on the
right shoulder and the Autobots Insignia
on the left shoulder here so that's
where we're at
and now
we continue on but again this is more of
a novelty idea than anything else I
think it's just kind of fun for
collectors out there to go hey look man
I got a Canon R5 that transforms
and most of that was just like this
Transformer thing just put like that
little model beside it yeah basically
that's it man you're gonna put the
camera next door to put an Optimus hands
and that's it you know you're gonna
leave it like that okay so we're at this
point now where the hands are out so you
know where the compartment is on the
camera where you have your headphones
and uh the Mike's alternator yeah right
here this portion pops open here I'm
just trying to get that out yeah it kind
of pushes down in here like that
I guess it's to leave some room for
something
now we bring
this piece up
and
just like that
oh it goes like
like that
that goes back onto his chest like this
now what you can do is you can put a
couple different things now you can hold
the arrow or the EOS R5
in the right hand and you're going to
use this with the articulating fingers
which by the way are pretty good it's
going to wrap around
this slot right here fits into the hand
so you just push that there and it's
going to just stay in the hand that way
because you can't use the fingers
there he goes push in like that close it
up Optimus is ready to take a photo
portrait mode or it's on portrait
landscape portrait landscape okay cool
then you can also put
The Matrix
as well but you can put this inside the
lens or you can hold the lens shield too
oh so you can actually use this as a
shield
got it so you take this portion down on
the lens cap
and it can actually be like a shield
they didn't use the articulating hands
hold that the fingers in place and you
can even figure that out Gerald can you
put that you see that that Ridge right
that hole right there in the hand yeah
you got to put that in
okay
there we go so now Optimus
has his
he's a cannon shooter
we got to get the Matrix inside this
thing do you see how that works you got
to go behind it there's a little bit of
a hinge ah there you go
there you go
okay and then that
there you go so there
The Matrix of what Matrix of friendship
okay
there's the Matrix of leadership right
there
inside the lens cap you close it up
here's the thing man we need some Windex
this list looks really foggy
do we have any like glass cleaner like
it looks really foggy man it's like a
haze you know what it is honestly
speaking it's just it's just the toy
because obviously this is not expensive
plastic here uh so look let's be honest
it's not going to win any awards for
um festival or anything yeah this is not
at all this is a novelty item through
and through is it worth 180 Singapore
dollars honestly
you got to be a fan of Transformers look
at this now he's doing the Jean-Claude
Van Damme
that's why like his legs just don't stay
nothing stays well on this it's all kind
of all over the place there's no locks
but
they're saying like that some of the
dials and these things work I mean
that's cute but
I mean it's okay it's not you can you
can move the knee a bit you can do this
kind of things
no waist doesn't rotate the knee joints
work the shoulders you can move this in
a little bit double uh a bit like that
you can do that but see it doesn't hold
like there's no tension there's not much
tension there so he's like he just wants
to go into splits man here's Optimus
Prime in his Jean-Claude Van Damme
stance against the 135 1.8 and the R5
holding him up final thoughts
um
um this is a very it feels like one of
these Transformers that you would find
and let's say one of those Street
Markets you know walking around where
it's like okay it's cute it's nice it's
interesting the idea is cool the concept
is cool I just wish they would have put
more thought into the the build Quality
quality better quality Plastics uh
better articulation the joints a little
bit more you know more attention to them
so you can stand and it can you can pose
them in different ways it is front heavy
so that will be a challenge to get them
to pose but again this is a fun little
collab right if you're a camera fan boy
a Canon Fanboy or fangirl you're going
to like this it's cool to have on the
Shelf if you're looking for someone
who's a Transformers collector and this
is something unique and you think hey
look I'll get it I don't care 180 200
Singapore dollars I'll buy it then pick
it up but don't expect much out of it
but it's fun right it's fun those are my
thoughts on the Canon Takara Tomy
Transformer collaboration the Optimus
Prime are five let me know your thoughts
in the comment section below is this
something you're looking to pick up any
questions you have I'll try to answer
those for you and if you like this
review check out more of our
Transformers videos right here
foreign
[Music]